[Music]
in close call news let's go submitted by
summer rain
a man's its today hailed on a spring
yeah oh hell no what no hail which was
the global warming you're talking about
it's global cooling a man's cell phone
protects him from an arrow attack [ __ ]
hidden uhm what an arrow right that was
my question someone he knows apparently
what the relationship he was [ __ ]
canoeing on the Amazonas [ __ ] no I do
archery and the jet was accident but the
the guys that live in the Amazon way
that scares me that I know sometimes
what you're thinking that's what the
[ __ ] here's a friendship cuz that's what
I thought like that's what I pictured he
was that's why I didn't he was like yeah
oh my god I just picked her on the
lollipop but I'm marrying you and but
you guys are the same person
remember the Tipsy roles if we found the
Native American guy shooting a star you
got a free Tootsie oh yeah [ __ ] you
forgot about the Native American guy
just thought it was a start
no he's shooting a three star yeah I'd
remember that mr. al how many licks does
it take to I hate like you sheisty
[ __ ] and I'm like no it's still
too cuz he licked it twice and you bit
the third one I'm like you so many
commercials it was like the black and
white thing right and a Tootsie Pops
tastes like [ __ ] just white and gold
pops all the way bow pop oh and the blue
ones you want oh and oh the chocolate
ones the most disgusting [ __ ] candy
was the Ring Pop because every kid has
slobber all over their [ __ ] I like
Ring Pop
guys you know when you share the Ring
Pop the when you suck on it like this
and then your pen sucking on it like
that just standing there with churches
and your friends like
never shared it I know my mom told me
that's germs I never shared it yeah well
we all share I don't know give me your
hand oh you guys like this yeah
like someone's sucking on it and they'll
be like oh I want some and you're like
okay and then you just have your fists
out like this I mean someone's like
we're not the same person we used to
have it at our babysitter's house and
we've all put them all in Captain Planet
came on yeah yes this takes place in
Australia and Australian 43 year old man
was left with a small cut on his chin
after to be like his phone blocked an
arrow oh well so he was like texting in
him no he was actually taking a photo of
the person who shot the arrow oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] take a picture of me no
they're saying he came under attack oh
sure yeah by this person that he
apparently knows he should have done it
on video oh so he was like I will take
pic unless it's a live video I would
take picture of him it wasn't a nice
picture it was like why did he do a
picture I know right well it doesn't
matter because the phone is ruined Oh
true and the phone actually saved him
because he was trying to take a photo or
whatever was like I should be in jail
for yeah but instead of attempted murder
God how did he survive I mean like
didn't he go after more after that
happened did he just like oh you know it
bothers me how I made this story is oh
they don't tell you the aftermath yeah
that's a lot arrows you can't reload
maybe it's like he got one shot off
after he saw like what could have
happened where's that oh I thought he
got scared I thought I'd try to kill him
in secret and then it went through his
phone he's like oh she saw me it looks
open of it he was trying to take a photo
of the guy with the bow and arrow
and then that like I guess when the guy
with the bow narrows thought he was
treating I don't know I don't really
know the full details cuz again it's
very big yeah but that's how it was
cause he was taking a picture he was
trying that the guy who shot the arrow
he's a 39 year old man he was charged
with assault and property damage
offenses that's an assault
how about tempted martyr I know that's
what I'm saying because that would have
been his skull right well yeah he got so
the phone because of the impact of the
arrow it kind of like bumped him in the
chin and then that's why you got a
little more thing out here too then
because it feels like here damn damn
martyr why do they get charged with that
no that means that if I could [ __ ]
swing this axe and it hits a phone it's
just a salt yeah well at least in
Australia that means if I was a killer
with the crossbow or with a boner in
Australia I would already just pre-press
all my arrows into phones that way as
I'm shooting they all have phones and if
I miss 20 times they're all just assault
times you know how much you want about
the Prime Minister and the band bow and
arrows now yeah cuz now they did all
assault bows they no assault both
regular bows are okay yeah it sounds
like we're saying bows like our friend
bows oh yeah yeah yeah anyway yeah
that's pretty crazy that it's a good
thing that he had his bone there to
protect them Oh like what do you call it
are trees Qantas bull you done it I did
it in school yeah in school yeah that we
had it for PE whoa that's tied eighth
grade oh she had a team like an archery
team and she I would not agree with the
Java arrow with the suction cup of no it
was like no our school would have never
had that
yeah there's this Park in the valley
that does it for free it's like there's
the archer la archery club or whatever
yeah and then you just sign up that day
and then you you just like you know go
in and you come on it's free cuz I know
you pay I went on with a couple people
you know what's not I think it might be
like donation or at the time is you
driving by you like Oh free archery I
would do that and then you go oh this is
cool
well they basically teach you they're
just trying to grow the archery
community and it's pretty sick like the
way that you shoot it too
you're not even like looking through it
like like yeah you just you're kind of
just feeling from the chest there's a
range in South Pasadena oh yeah yeah
we must go axe throwing is pretty
[ __ ] fun oh yeah the back story is
pretty sure I want you to do that so bad
it's a little harder than I thought you
I'm gonna tell you something else man do
like these caught on camera first time
doing it
stuck it oh time the better bull they
pretty close one hand one hand oh did
you burn or after that I so the first
one I got the second one I missed why
don't you go we did it for sin foods
episode mmm and I was actually shocked
that I actually wouldn't come today
hurting me like I feel like they would
backfire on me you know what it is it's
the apprehension that [ __ ] people up
with it right yeah I mean I think if you
play a sport and that guy there's a guy
coaching you how to do it yeah they
teach you for the coach so it's a lot of
its apprehension because there's not
enough momentum for that axe to get
moment to stay straight and hit the
target so people will try to love it so
when it lobs it gets very wobbly and the
smacks against is you actually following
through chucking it it'll stick I always
saw as hard as I can first I'd dial back
after well you have to do some politic
because he was like a lot of people they
throw down yeah and then you're just
supposed to like let go and then you go
like like you're supposed to like let go
right one is straight but what people do
they throw it so hard that it's like
going downwards just throwing
in my backyard my mom came home and saw
that all her kitchen utensils all bet
and [ __ ] up I got my ass beat fruit
knives are like vegetable knife there's
no wake you up it's really her father
left him alone
Oh knew that like a seven or
eight-year-olds gonna ransack what do we
got to play in Bordeaux over and over
again at that table dude you had been
the worst child to have ever I would sit
there I would beat your [ __ ] ass and
I will go to my room and cry cuz I have
a child like that after I begged her if
I could get the throwing knife set from
big five it she said no what how was
that a defense she could have got me
something for like 1999 and I would have
to touch her kitchen utensils plastic I
need something real and then you go into
the kitchen you're like real knives
how'd you even find throwing knives that
as a seven year old got everything every
five telescopes running shoes [ __ ]
Chinese medicine ball things I got
everything there [ __ ] it's a kind of
dumb cuz I didn't do that but I did
definitely when my parents got these
Cutco knives they were so [ __ ] sharp
I just started missus before the fruit
ninja game bells fruit ninja everything
in the house dude
Oh toss in the air because of the you
know the miracle blade commercial where
they would cut the pineapple in half oh
yeah yeah yeah no [ __ ] fruit alive in
my home I had a tennis racket and I
would get a bunch of lemons go smack the
limit as hard as I can into though of
the cinderblock wall it just wanna make
watch him explode our friends that for a
YouTube channel and he gets millions of
views yeah just kiss all the it's all
kids watch kids watching and living
vicariously through him oh you're right
I know a nice vlog I did you hear what
he just said he goes he's the why idea
1991 yeah so he saw you probably I used
to have lemon fights with my neighbor 11
party emails that you get do you ever
get 11 party email no do you know what
I'm talking about no what is that you
guys never got a lemon party email oh my
god okay so it was like in the late
night news Mon or whatever all right was
it a leap own party okay so there was a
lemon party email was back when like AOL
was first around so like at no one
really knew like oh I got an email like
there wasn't like you are aware of scams
or anything like that so you would say
like you're invited to the lemon party
and then you click on it and it's a
bunch of dudes [ __ ] each other it's
like I'm not doing that kind of a party
party make the cut oh we had a big lemon
tree that fell in their backyard and in
our backyard right and we would just
like be tossing lemons over all over the
fence and then we got it to a big lemon
fight so I was like yeah it was pretty
fun one thing's for sure though
definitely have super soakers cuz super
soldiers were flying always wanted one
you never got one you need to knock off
once you know which one I wanted the
fact that rich kids had that [ __ ] yeah
that was for so good three thousands all
that other [ __ ] dude this [ __ ] was so
tight man I had one issues though you
had the ones that you pumped
yeah well cuz after my parents got
divorced I got to ask my dad for a toy
and I could guilt-trip them oh my mom
didn't get me one I think is talking
about good side so I got hella toys when
I got divorced oh yeah that's one of the
best sides of divorce
[Laughter]